we've been discussing this amazing 2nd
paragraph of the Declaration of
Independence we've gotten through what
passes for the first two sentences they
use all sorts of weird punctuation here
and now they're going on to say that
whenever any form of government becomes
destructive of these ends it's the right
of the people to alter or abolish it and
to institute new government laying its
foundation on such principles as
organizing its powers in such form as to
them shall seem most likely to effect
their safety and happiness and just to
make sure because they're the writing in
a very uh yeah they get a bit ornate and
they're ornate and they added that first
set it's a whole lot it's very clear but
this sentence is a little bit order when
they write that whenever any form of
government becomes destructive of these
ends they're talking again of the life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
right in other words in other words if
you have a king who's taken away
people's life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness so this is I talking about the
English government not just the
Parliament but the king nail has become
destructive of these unalienable rights
that was supposed to protect yeah and
that we did form a new government to
affect their safety and happiness right
but most importantly it's the right of
the people to alter or abolish it in
other words they're saying something
that is not yet been quite accepted by
history which is if you're a people and
you don't like your government you can
overthrow it we hadn't had that many
revolutions you know in the past 200
years leading up to that and this is the
beginning of an age of revolution where
people say oh yeah we have the right to
abolish our government whoa
that's a holy now people doing it not
another king not another ruler
that's why history is other Kings
exactly most of history I mean for the
hundred years leading up to this
document France and England have been
fighting each other the kings of England
have been trying to supplant the kings
of France and there's been a hundred
years war it's been in you know the
American Revolution sort of a part of
that but something different happens
here is not one king trying to overthrow
another King it's the right of the
people to up
polish and institute a new government to
protect their own safety and happiness
the next sentence prudence indeed will
dictate that governments long
established should not be changed for
light and transient causes that
basically is saying you know you
shouldn't go around doing this all the
time you have to have a really really
good reason because it's not as if just
because you're kind of annoyed at your
government you should overthrow it and
this is why they have a pretty long
document ahead of them this is just the
first to power day and this is important
this I guess reminds us of what this
whole document is for this is to
communicate with the rest of the world
and as you mentioned also France like
that that look you know we're not we're
not crazy folks here we recognize this
is a serious thing we're doing that we
don't take this lightly that's what that
tenant says exactly which is you
shouldn't do it just for light and
transient causes we're going to have to
show you that we've got some real good
reasons to do it and that's what it goes
on to say especially like while evils
are sufferable than to right themselves
by abolishing the forms to which they
are customs in other words these are
powerful words sort of saying that you
know these are the type of things you
really have to raise up arms against and
so then let's go to the Senate okay and
I find this one really interesting it's
a kind of a less famous part of it but
it says and accordingly all experience
hath shown that mankind are more
disposed to suffer while evils are
sufferable than to right themselves by
abolishing the forms to which they're
custom so that it's really saying that
normally men even when their rice start
to get imposed they kind of just go
along you know it's kind of like a frog
when boiling water they're just kind of
live with it but but this but when it
gets too bad yeah that's when you have
to take up arms and you're right that's
the whole point of that is that
experience has shown we kind of just go
along with bad Kings just like we go
along with good Kings you know but this
is special this is different with their
secondary and that's why they start the
next sentence with the word but it's
sort of this is the but this is
different
senator why is it different but when a
long train of abuses and usurpations
usurpations means
hey they're taking away our powers
pursuing invariably the same object
evinces a desire to reduce them under
absolute despotism in other words what's
happened is the king and his Parliament
have decided to reduce it so that they
have all the powers the taxing without
our consent that doing all sorts of
things they're quartering troops in our
homes that's when they say it goes on to
say it is their right in other words the
right of us our people it is their duty
to throw off such government and to
provide new guards for their future
security
I mean think about that how often had
that been happening before yeah yeah
especially for for the people to do it
right I mean we very rarely have had a
people led rebellion to say you've
usurped you these usurpations usurped
our rights there's been a long train of
abuses and you've reduced us to absolute
despotism actually Jefferson when he
writes that phrase has an even you know
grander Fraser's or that's right
everything else and Franklin says I
think we're going a bit overboard here
let's just say reduce them under
absolute despotism which means you've
taken away all of our rights you've
become a despot No then you know it's
been he goes on to say such has been the
patient sufferance of these colonies in
other words we've been pretty patient
upright you put on a tea tack you put on
a paper tax you put on a Stamp Act you
haven't you taxation without
representation you haven't allowed us to
be part of the Parliament voting on our
own taxes so we've been pretty patient
of these things and such is now the
necessity which constrains them meaning
constrains us the people of the United
States to alter their former systems of
government and now is when they set up
what is going to be the rest of the
document they attack the king the
history of the present King of Great
Britain that we have them up there
George the third you know there is yes
okay looking kind of nice like yeah I'm
not only worst of all I might get some
bows myself right right
definitely like a royal person but the
history of this present King of Great
Britain is history of repeated injuries
and usurpations they all have all having
in direct object the establishment of an
absolute Tyranny over these states now
you know what I think they were
overstating it a bit I mean I'm not
trying to be kind to King George here
but what they did is they tax the t-they
taxes and they were using the tax
revenues to help support the colonies
I think Parliament felt that well you
could argue a little bit that we're
taxing without getting your consent but
I think they would say hey wait
absolute Tyranny you know injuries and
repeated injuries and usurpations
they're going too far and there was a
lot of people at least half the people
in the colonies that kind of agreed with
English they were still loyal and so
what they do Jefferson Franklin and
Adams and the people writing this is
they say we're going to have to show you
while we're using this strong language
it's a wonderful sentence to me to prove
this let facts be submitted to a candid
world that's what this declaration is we
are going to give you all the facts and
try to prove it's been absolute Tyranny
that we've been suffering and they work
themselves up into convincing themselves
and probably the rest of it to be fair
to them you know probably in 1774 or
even march of 1775 they might have felt
like that but now blood there was
bloodshed now right I have been killed
and now of course people are definitely
going to be much more passionate about
want you I mean yeah I guess you could
you know sense it in your own sense of
history once people start fighting they
get themselves a bit worked up I could
absolutely absolutely and it's British
troops on American soil it's American
families American fathers were dying and
that's how they could imagine they would
start to see these things right it
starts to get out of hand without their
intention the Continental Congress
didn't declare a war back in 1775 you
have a bunch of militia people in
Lexington and Concord getting all riled
up by Paul Revere
yeah because the British are coming to
take some of the munitions out of the
out of the Arsenal's in Lexington and
Concord so he's writing and saying the
British are coming and then the
militiamen come out and suddenly up in
Massachusetts is revolution that even
most of the people in the Continental
Congress weren't quite ready for has
begun to happen and you know do you I
mean you sunset one thing spit and then
and then after this they go on and list
that's the rest of the document the rest
of the Declaration is just line after
line of the King has done this the King
has done that and most importantly as
you see in this the history of the
present King of Great Britain they're
revolting now against the king not just
the Parliament that has voted these
taxes but they're saying it's a king
himself that were rebelling against and
that's what made it a true revolution
rather than just trying to get rid of
the Parliament which is temporary
fascinating